so starting this morning more people are
now eligible to get the coveted vaccine
here in southern nevada
that includes certain front-line
professions hector mckee live this
morning with who can now make an
appointment hey hector
hey there alex good morning to you under
this new guidance from the southern
nevada health district
the new groups now include community
support supply chain and logistics so
let's go over this information
this now means that thousands of more
workers are now
eligible for the vaccine but keep in
mind it all depends on availability
the new group now includes essential
transportation personnel
say airport workers along with taxi and
ride share
drivers plus those in agriculture and
food processing those who make up supply
chains
grocery store warehouse workers and
truck drivers
also joining the new group are n dot
local emergency road crews
utilities and communications personnel
they join those already eligible for the
vaccine including
people 65 and older teachers health care
workers and first responders to groups
we've been telling you about
the convention center here right next to
us is one of the massive vaccination
sites we also have catchment center
and i called yesterday the southern
nevada health district when they
announced about this new group being
eligible
and they told me that sometime today the
health district will be accepting
appointments for the newly eligible
groups
reporting live this morning hector mejia
8 news now some really good news
all right hector thank you so much for
that and